let's do this dock update Jeff recently
talked about how David didn't want him
to make the documentary now he had
discussed that with us also but what's
different now is that he shared some
receipts of text messages and videos of
David's and Natalie his assistants
participation here's Natalie texting
with Jeff hi I just saw Jeff's tweet
this is uh someone on Jeff's team one of
Jeff's friends oh from his the people
are talking don't want to bother him but
how'd the edit turn out good we cut out
the screenshot and changed some verbiage
in bad shape today though oh man what
does Natalie respond okay cool did you
guys add the teaser stuff for the
positive note at the end oh my God okay
cool he's he's in really rough shape
okay right on he's not doing well sick
all right cool how little empathy can
you have to type out cool and like make
that choice after reading that she chose
not to see that clearly mean Choice
she's gold driven and that's why he
likes her